David everybody talks about
neoliberalism can you talk about what
that actually means what does it mean to
be neoliberal and is it a smear okay the
the second part is easy too easier to
answer people who are against
neoliberalism tend to use it as a smear
people who are neoliberal tend not to
use the term at all it's sort of like
when when the right talks about social
Darwinism is it is a terrible thing
nobody on the Left uses the term it's a
term that mostly exists to smear people
you disagree with neoliberal is a thing
it's it's much more a real practical
definable thing in modern politics but
it's mostly people criticizing
neoliberalism that use the term
so let's first try to figure out what it
originally meant and then we can think
about how it's applied now neoliberal
sort of means small-l liberalism with a
tendency to support free-market
capitalism so I don't mean capital L
liberalism like the Liberal Party in the
UK or liberalism as progressivism but I
mean liberalism as the the sort of
nineteenth-century
laissez-faire liberalism a combined or
modernized with some particular
perspectives that include deregulation
of businesses the Reagan tax cuts were
sort of part of more modern 20th century
neoliberalism more defense spending
often is in line with modern
neoliberalism what else deregulation of
the financial industry deregulation of
trucking and banking and Airlines so
there's if we imagine Neal that we if we
imagine liberalism as sort of a late
19th century movement neoliberalism is
the way in which it was restructured and
updated starting sort of in the early
1970s Mecca nama CLE it's it's typically
just interwove on with supply-side
economics the sort of trickle-down tax
cuts for the rich for good forever
buddy type of stuff it's not just
Republicans that are neoliberal or do
neoliberal politics Bill Clinton passing
NAFTA the North American Free Trade
Agreement that was a widely accepted
neoliberal thing to do but but the sort
of underlying ideas are privatization of
things that should be or were public
deregulation cutting government spending
under the pretense of the debt as we've
talked about that political football and
turning over more and more of the
economy to private companies and that's
where it kind of gets into foreign
policy because right now in the United
States when critics of neoliberalism
talk about neoliberalism they're often
talking more about foreign policy than
they are tax cuts although certainly as
I mentioned supply-side economics and
tax cuts for the rich are part of the
early neoliberal ideas of the 70s and
80s the Iraq war and Afghanistan war
came from neoliberal ideology upbringing
order as we see it to other regions the
idea of spreading democracy like for
example as the 2003 Iraq war claim to
want to do in Iraq that is a neoliberal
idea what makes this a little difficult
is that there's actually a split within
neoliberalism about interventionism
generally speaking neoliberalism is for
foreign intervention but it doesn't
always mean military intervention so a
lot of the people on the right who are
against military interventions in many
cases under sort of libertarian ideas it
doesn't mean they aren't neoliberal they
often just favor intervention via soft
power democracy quiet support for coos
and sort of other geopolitical tactics
that are out there so there's not one
definition of neoliberalism anytime that
we have an ideology that is often
defined by its opponents we have to be
sort of cognizant of the fact that that
that is a thing
in thinking about what is part of it and
what isn't part of it but that's sort of
a basic structure for what neoliberalism
means in practice right now in the 21st
century